this morning on the dish a familiar face
in a new place chef alfred portale has
spent nearly four decades in the
culinary sphere
a pioneer in the new american food
movement with multiple james beard
awards a michelin star
unprecedented reviews and three
best-selling cookbooks portale has
little to prove
but that didn't stop him from leaving
the iconic new york restaurant he helped
build
to open a place of his own
with a new year's themed brunch as
inspiration we're going to taste
a pasta that we put together it's a
maine lobster it's got a little bit of
chervil and some salmon roll on top
barrow in an italian staple served with
walnut oil and wild mushrooms
rack of lamb with chicante beans some
braised escarole
shaved black truffle on here as well and
lastly for dessert a chocolate
and coffee tiramisu delicious chef
alfred portale
sat down to reflect so this is called a
spallata
it translates to a mistake and the story
goes the bartender was making a negroni
and he reached for the gin but he ended
up with some prosecco
a couple of parts campari and vermouth
and proseccos
cheers cheers to that i like mistakes
after more than three decades as
executive chef and partner of new york's
iconic
gotham bar and grill portale knows a
thing or two about mistakes
and even more about successes the james
beard award winner's latest venture is
also his first
solo endeavor his namesake portale
what is the pressure then like when you
say okay leaving that
i'm going to start this you didn't think
about that before you did it
i did think about it what did you want
that restaurant to be i wanted it to be
many things i wanted to be an expression
of myself i tried to create
a very chic and sort of sexy and fun
and lively place for the food he turned
to a combination of his personal
and culinary past both of my
grandparents
are from sicily actually but all my
training is french
sort of the bold passion of italy and
the precision of french cooking that's
how we
we look at it i guess italian food is in
your blood is that yes big italian
american family
lots of cousins my mother was an
excellent cook
her red sauce turned into your white
sauce
is that right oh that's funny my mom
used to make a big pot of red sauce with
the meatballs and brazil and all the
i carry on that tradition you know i've
tweaked them over the years
it's a white bolognese so made with
short rib and
some black truffle it's a nice dish my
whole career i've always
looked for classic dishes classic flavor
combinations
and tried to give it a personal touch
that kind of creative expression
part of what drew portale to cooking in
the first place
from early childhood i wanted to be an
artist you know it started with a next
door neighbor
who was a painter and used to give me
art lessons
when i was i must have been eight years
old nine years old
what did you love about it you know it's
just the creative
aspect of it being able to design and
express yourself that way
somehow i was turned on to cooking
through
some old french cookbooks that had
illustrations of these
big elaborate buffets that they used to
do in the 20s and 30s
and i said this is edible art which is
exactly what portale would go on to
create
building a following and reputation with
his masterpieces
at gotham bar and grill at portale his
creative touch
is still found in the architecture of
the food but also
in the space itself i had a great deal
to do with the design
the integration of art and music all
sort of with a postmodern
sort of vibe to it cooking is related to
art in some ways because
you know it's instant gratification so
you create a wonderful dish
and get it into production and serve it
to a guest
i mean i think that's the reward one
thing out of portale's control
timing his restaurant's launch was in
the fall of 2019
just a few months before the pandemic
began
could anything have prepared you for it
i don't even have to finish the question
yeah could anything have prepared you no
i mean
who could have ever conceived something
like this i mean
you know it's it's it's it's really
tough for for restaurants
um during this time for sure
i feel for my staff and everyone in the
industry that's been
impacted by this much of portale staff
is more like
family after so many years of working
together
and it was family he thought of when i
asked him our traditional dish question
if you could have this meal with anyone
past or present oh wow
who would it be you know we spoke about
her earlier and
i thought about her a lot i do miss my
mom
you know she was she was important did
she get to see a lot of your
success yeah they did actually you know
they
god blessed them they lived into their
90s but
yeah i came to new york came to gotham
on a number of occasions
but always kept me really well grounded
you know i'm like mom you know i'm on tv
i get it we just got three stars from
the new york times
you didn't call me last week right
something like that yeah something like
that
what would she think of the white sauce
oh god well
i think she'd be skeptical at first but
once she tasted it
maybe next i think i'd win it over
strong
and cheers to mom and the white sauce i
couldn't bring you food but i did make a
drink i don't know how i do as a
bartender but
was already drinking during the piece
[Music]
i saw it it's a wonderful mistake
that's all i know it's very strong and
portale is still doing an outdoor dining
program they're going right now
like all restaurants just trying to make
the best of it